Next question. Last time you did a cheek swab, the cause tested as toxicity. You mentioned a couple
tests for toxicity, but I don't remember what they are. Also, Iverbechtin didn't test
for me, but Fenbenazole did. Is there anything else like Iverbechtin that works synergistically with
Fenbenazole? I don't think that Iverbechtin works synergistically with Fenbenazole. So, I don't know
of anything that works. The things that work synergistically with Fenbenazole are typically
thought of as like curcumin, can, vitamin E, can, burberry, can, CBD, can. I don't believe
Fenbenazole that Iverbechtin is a synergistic beneficial component of the Fenbenazole protocol.
There are two different things. So, something that works synergistically with it is
something that increases the effectiveness of one or both products. So, curcumin, for instance, can
increase the effectiveness of Fenbenazole. But I don't think Iverbechtin increases the effectiveness
of Fenbenazole, nor does Fenbenazole increase the effectiveness of Iverbechtin.